Cova civic all right 5 4 3 2 1 boom
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are sitting down with Jian eco
vasilich hello nice to be here
thanks for joining us on the show SFO
here we are I said well here we are yeah
and we're gonna be talking about the
global energy matrix realistic
environmentalism these are kind of like
both actually your quote is so
fascinating that the umbilical cord of
human progress is energy yeah yeah
that's also abstract because it's talk
about electricity you don't see it it's
behind the wall it's inside your car
it's in every facility it makes your
life comfortable and the world has about
seven and a half billion people a couple
billion people still don't have access
to electricity so how is it possible
that someone sitting in San Francisco or
New York or Berlin Germany can tell
someone in India or Africa you're never
gonna have running water in your house
you're never gonna have the magnificence
of electricity in your home to operate
something like a refrigerator or a
washing machine
not possible so eventually everyone is
going to have these things but how how
do we make it possible how is everyone
gonna access energy I'll tell you one
thing it won't be the way we or our
parents or our grandparents access to
energy for the first time and that's
we're going to talk about today let's
stay with the feeling of abstraction for
a little bit when we all walk into our
house and flick on the light switch
we have no idea usually how the energy
is actually getting there when we hop
into an automobile we usually have no
idea where the gasoline is coming from
in there to power it we have such
energies one of them probably has the
highest rate of use with the lowest rate
of knowing where it comes from with the
highest rate of abstraction
- it Carl Sagan is a famous science
fiction ax stand he once said I'll
paraphrase that are the exact quote but
something about knowing a little bit
about the sunset doesn't take any of the
romance out of the equation and so I
always tell people whether you're an
investor I just part of society to
understand a little bit about energy and
hopefully people can articulate that so
it resonates you got to put it in the
you know in a way that people can
actually relate to it and of course when
you talk about the electricity for
example if you cut it in half what does
it look like what is it what does it
take to make it possible and because we
effectively why do I use the word
electrification so much when you take
fossil fuels out of the energy mix
you're basically going to a world of
electrification that's what wind power
is that's what solar panels are electric
cars and that they all work together but
with an increased amplitude of
electrification going away from the
internal combustion engine we went from
the animal age to the Machine age and
it's effectively been the internal
combustion engine but when we start
weaning ourselves off of the internal
combustion engine there's going to be
countless billions more of electrical
motors in every shape and size yeah okay
so we talk about abstraction and how we
almost have this black box of energy
right now but knowing a little bit more
about it is actually really important
and then you also mention how we're not
gonna be accessing the electricity in
the same way that our parents their
grandparents did and there's still parts
of the world that are coming online in
terms of energy you have that really
good photo actually do you want to pull
up the photo of Africa the one the dark
photo of the earth and then there's that
gold square
yeah yeah did we get that one index yeah
the one of Africa the one that's like a
darker photo of the continent and then
there's like a gold box around it yeah
yeah I said it do you have it it's okay
so there's this really good photo of
Africa and there's it's a dark photo of
Africa dark night photo satellite photo
at night and then there's a gold square
around it and around mostly the
sub-saharan area and then it's a it's
all dark because it's not lit up like we
have at night in the United States and
in Asia and Europe we are very lit up at
night and so you wrote that there's a
billion people that live in that non lid
square yeah the sub-saharan Africa
excluding South Africa it's a put that
in a different area but sub-saharan
Africa excluding South Africa has about
900 million people the the energy or
electrical capacity of that area is
about less than 30 gigawatts got to make
that resonate with people America's
electrical capacity is 1100 gigawatts so
if you drive by a large power plant
that's what gives us electricity
typically there are a thousand megawatts
thousand megawatts one gigawatt we don't
want to get too technical with people
but it's easy to remember one one
gigawatt is a large power plant yeah so
just imagine you've got three times the
population in the United States and they
have three percent of the electrical
capacity they're not going to obtain
their first electricity many parts of
that of the African content with grid
the way we did it's gonna happen in a
micro setting which is going to be
batteries it's gonna be small solar
panels and they're gonna charge maybe
some lights heating element to come food
charge their electrical goodies and
eventually that'll increase and I'll
have more access to electricity there's
the picture there thanks Ron
yeah that's the photo right there so
okay now you were as we identify this
area and we identify that the current
amount of gigawatts that are being
consumed here are significantly less
than four three times as many people
then you describe these different ways
of almost it's like leap frogging in
terms of technology that if certain
areas of the world pick up oh my god I
just saw you're up right above it like
you're up in comparison is crazy to
compare it to um and then you were
discussing these different ways of of
the way that they're going to access
technology and these necks coming and
energy in these next coming years are
going to be different than the way that
we accessed it and so there's gonna be
is there going to be a complete skip of
this burning fossil fuels to solar or to
wind or alternatively yes and no going
away from fossil fuels is a really easy
prescription too right yeah but a much
harder one to take yeah you know you
have to go to maybe a country that's a
little bit more populated maybe it's
already advanced and you want to talk
about examples like Japan or China or if
you look at a country like Germany or
Italy why do I mention these places they
import fossil fuels so if I embellish a
map of the world this this is a one such
map but if I embellish a different one
picture this in the theater of your mind
if you have those countries that export
oil the more oil they export and the
higher the price of oil them on this map
the more significant that country
becomes what pops up in the middle Saudi
Arabia Iran Iraq Kuwait United Arab
Emirates Angola Venezuela countries like
that well that's one way to look at that
but you to think like the Japanese or
the Chinese or the Italians or the
Germans they import this product I can
assure you for 120 hundred 30 years that
that was the business cycle but now that
there are options they have there are
ways that over a 10 or 20 year period
they can to wean their wean themselves
not to zero but basically not don't what
rather than continue to grow the
demand for those other products like oil
we just talked about should decrease
when the Japanese and the Chinese
innovate these things that are expert
economies they're gonna export that
technology to guess where Africa and the
Africans are gonna buy this new type of
energy energy mix or energy basket so
the analogy that's been well used as
people in India they never had a
landline they went from no phone to the
mobile phone so the same thing has
happened in Africa so they will not have
big grid power not everywhere industry
does it does require that but but in a
micro level micro setting these hundreds
millions of people are gonna access
energy electricity not in the in the in
the incumbent ways it's gonna happen way
faster than people think or appreciate
fact it's already happening it's
happening right before our eyes I like
how you said appreciate it's really
important to actually have gratitude for
all of the different technological
advances that are making our lives
better
so same similarly to how India
leapfrogged
from with no landline we have Africa
potentially leapfrog with no grid system
some places will still have now this is
a very complicated equation to global
energy matrix super complicated I think
a frequent incorrect way to look at
things maybe it's a myopic way of
looking at things is binary thinking
around energy either it's always only
renewables from here on out or it's only
coal and fossil fuels right now and so
there's so much more nuance there's so
much more of a multi variability that's
in the mix in this global energy matrix
I think a good question to ask you while
you're here is as we are continuing to
use fossil fuels to power innovation and
power the United States being a massive
energy consumer but also a massive
innovator how do we find that cool
balance strike between continuing to
implement lots of altern
of energy programs and transition and to
help the world transition at the same
time as making sure that we're still
trudging along with being able to
consume as much energy as we need to
innovate you put put the picture up of
of the Donald with Jim Justice if you
could the leaders in green energy
typically typically have been the
Chinese they did not they had to address
particulate pollution so there's there's
two arguments here one is climate change
and there's people that are climate
change deniers okay we're not going to
talk about that today and then you have
an economy like China which is we we saw
the pollution in the cities which is
actually a global situation I show you
Paris I show you London Mumbai you could
see many cities that have particulate
pollution they had to address that so
they do not consider it like being
bludgeoned in the head with a 2x4
because you have to address these things
they are now the leaders innovators in
solar panels photovoltaic solar wind
power curtailment with these things
which are working on now electric buses
electric cars charging and the greater
infrastructure for all these things oh
and guess what
they export that to the world now yeah
they're the leaders so this picture what
this is showing it took place last year
August of 2017 and Jim Justice is the
governor of West Virginia he was elected
as a Democrat and he he converted he
became a Republican and Donald came to
West Virginia and he announced that this
was happening and Jim Justice made a
fortune selling Appalachian thermal coal
and he was having a hard time getting a
subsidy for coal you can't make this up
there are people within the green energy
sphere and a lot of people don't
recognize this they believe that
subsidies are unfairly put towards
renewables which is subsidies are put
towards all energy on a global basis
actually more goes towards fossil fuels
than does renewable so if you talk about
every form of energy across the world
but to finish this point he was asking
for a 15 tolerant on subsidy because
coal generating electricity from thermal
coal does not compete with natural gas
mm-hmm and we use natural gas to augment
renewables because renewables are
intermittent and depending where you are
in the United States taxes lots of wind
in the southern belt lots of Sun
but it does it's not sunny all the time
and it's not windy all the time the
reason we like to use natural gas 1 we
have lots of it we have energy
independence in the United States that's
a good thing but it's also in North
Dakota it's everywhere we have we have
gas in many many four formations or
across the United States Marcellus up in
Pennsylvania and Ohio we have it all
through Texas Oklahoma Colorado it's
it's fast it's best but it's
instantaneous when you argument
renewables you need a base load
electricity source could be a battery we
can't make batteries big enough yet
natural gas it's a light switch so
normal coal not a light switch you have
to turn it on it takes days to turn on
and off nuclear power takes like as much
as a month so they're not good
intermittent power sources and so when
you look at this graphic here
interesting now you're reinvesting what
is it investors a society you want to
invest in the future into technology so
that's that's the old incumbent system
it's still important we do rely on a
portion of our electricity from coal but
if we have the ways and means over the
period of the next 10 20 years
assets that are deemed on economic our
assets that will be stranded totally it
has nothing to do with subsidies it's
all about the money and the gravity the
investors are gonna gravitate that way
and in this case it's also the
application so the intermittent
transitionary period that we're in two
alternative forms of energy are actually
really for heavily depending on natural
gas in this intermittent it's very
important part of mix and emissions wise
they're depending on the emission there
are different types of emissions but
there is about half of the emissions you
have with natural gas compared to coal
so but it we're after something is
baseload forever now as a bridge there's
a 20-year bridge not gonna be five years
is there's a long term one of your
bridge or 20 or 30 it's when you're 30
or bridge and natural gas has about half
as many emissions as coal yeah yeah okay
ok and then so ok so the number of
Spindletop that you could put up let's
do it that's the the car with the big
derrick now the the would Derek nope ah
is it that one is it this one
no that's why I drove an electric car
across America yeah to prove a point
yeah that point is the future is now so
I I drove from from Boston to Florida to
California back up to Vancouver that's
the picture back up to Vancouver Canada
and I'm oh no can we get onto your book
tour after another question about this
intermittent period sure so because
we're one of that that's gonna be really
good we're gonna segue right into that
the this intermittent period as we're
going through you leveraging natural gas
to continue to power our economy 5% of
the population 25% of the energy
consumption of the planet so we got a
lot of energy that we need to consume in
order to power the homes that we have
and to power the innovation that we do
so what does it look like that what
we're in now today as you're about to
describe your tour that you did your
book tour for zero mission book tour as
well as kind of what's going on with
electrification Shenzhen 15,000 electric
buses are out now 50 electric car
companies in China where do we where do
we sit today and in these next couple of
years as how much fossil how much
natural gas do we need to use as we
transition to electrification complete
electrification as a planet well that's
going to be way in the distant future
because the the low-hanging fruit is
actually efficiency hmm so the
the average internal combustion engine
and there are four areas where we use
oil in transportation for sort of
buckets and collectively fifty-five
percent of all the oil that is consumed
is consumed in transportation fuels in
cargo ships right so it in in in four
buckets but forty five percent of the
oil that's consumed on a global basis is
used to make enhanced products plastic
polyester petrochemicals things like
that 55 percent transit forty five
percent yes so of those four buckets of
transportation six percent each is
aviation in the maritime trade that's
not gonna change too much those good
planes will be more efficient but
there's gonna be more of them and then
you have that the two big buckets are
road freight and passenger vehicles
interesting and how big are those 25 and
19 percent respectively 25 being road
freight road freight
Wow road freight is just burning through
yeah but but these things will all
become more efficient they will not go
to zero not in ten years not in 20 years
so electrification will play a role yeah
but it's it's a really efficiency the
low-hanging fruit where the internal
combustion engine will continue to
become more efficient and it will be
displaced by things like electrification
and hydrogen fuel cells for certain
applications it makes sense as well but
it'll still be I think well what society
and industry government collectively has
to go after right now is efficiency
because that is there it's available and
we've seen when you look at the most
efficient air conditioner compared to
the the worst of the least efficient
there's a big difference
same with a really old inefficient
automobile and a brand-new efficient
even if it is an internal combustion
engine right so there's a big difference
there so the old school computers that
we used to use sources beyond ones today
so I think efficiency is the is where
one thing we need and it is being
addressed I mean there the previous
administration came up with the
efficiency of back then it was announced
2018 in 2023 certain things electrically
had to be far more efficient namely they
were going after things like
refrigeration and an air conditioning
for things that consume electricity
okay so right now the main thing to look
at is efficiencies
in energy out okay and this is lots of
losses when you make electricity
there's losses when you make it when you
transmit it when you utilize it and
these major buckets this is this one
this actually is a pretty interesting
aspect of this bucket
if 55 percent are for transit most
people don't even realize that about
half of it 45 percent is for goods oil
used for goods yeah when you process a
barrel of oil or natural gas that's
called cracking and it's basically a
process of evaporation and and at
different temperatures and you you
weaned off various different products
out of it three or four or five things
or transportation fuels the rest is an
enhanced product you can imagine so
there's a big it's a big growth business
actually and a lot of the refining
capacity around the world is calibrating
for a future of in more enhanced
products and less transportation fuels
things like diesel or kerosene relays
it's not yet and will will be used for
goods all right let's get to let's get
to was a 15 minute timer we'll throw
that up and if we end up you still have
some time between before you need to
leave so if we have some time we can
maybe spend a little bit more time this
quick question that's separation that
you described 55 percent on transit and
then figuring out efficiencies there and
then also 45 percent on goods oil use
and figuring out efficiencies there
we're gonna continue using oil for
transit and for goods for an extended
period of a couple decades and that's
going as we transition to renewable now
as you are an energy consultant going
around and talking to so many people
with your new book as well going in
doing a zero-emission book tour when
you're talking to people about what you
know and what you've experienced as an
energy strategist and consultant what
have been some of these profound tako
I hope you put up the picture again in
Spindletop with the with the wood
derrick and that this is in Texas and
this is a museum that commemorates the
world's first true oil gusher it was
discovered by an immigrant to the United
States his name was Anton Lucic he was
born in Croatia in 1855 and he went to
the Graz Polytechnic where all the
enlightened people
the Croatians I am yeah of the
austro-hungarian Empire would go came to
America working as a salt mine engineer
they sent him to South Texas he saw the
sulfur domes and he figured that if we
drill we could probably find oil and on
January 10 1901 they discover massive
oil under pressure and it was gushing to
the rate of about a hundred thousand
barrels of oil a day it was the world's
first true oil gusher yeah and that
happened Allen and coincident with all
of the machinery that came came
basically was being invented and
commercialized at the time December 1903
the first airplane Kittyhawk North
Carolina
you've got automobiles and then you had
the assembly line with with Henry Ford
1908 October 1908 perfected by 1913
Winston Churchill would convert the
naval fleet of the British Empire with
largest in the world in 1910 1911 from
coal to liquid fuel and then what
happens the world goes to war 1914 why
something that's less appreciated is if
you look at the countries it was the
haves against the have-nots
it was Bismarck's reunified Germany
austria-hungary and the Ottoman Empire
against Russia
France England and you could look at it
the countries that colonize the world
that had the large naval fleets the -
300 years before and the countries that
did not colonize the world we found out
at that time between the year 1900 and
the 1910 that if you did not have
commodities in particular oil you could
not grow Wow could not grow and so it
became so important but the center the
sphere of influence was the United
States they found oil in the Middle East
not not in Saudi Arabia but in in in
Persia Iran Iraq Kuwait 1908 and onward
and it was the absolutely with
question it was the the power in the
global economy yeah oil
yeah and now all the way till today now
there are alternatives now there are
alternatives and it's a big pivot it's a
paper that's gonna take society 20 or 30
years but the tools are available for
people to actually address that and it
goes back to that earlier sentiment just
to stay with that history lesson real
quick because it's very underappreciated
to be able to immerse ourselves in
previous time periods and what humanity
has went through to get to where we are
today and we like to do that as much as
possible on the show in the very early
1900's the right beginning of them if
you did not have access to oil you could
not grow that's correct
it was paramount and that's to do
everything you need across building your
cities to transiting the goods to making
trade to doing all different types of
work what was the lubricant in the
1800's the lubricant was whale oil whale
oil was so important to the American
economy in the 1800's it was the maybe
the fifth or sixth largest employer
it was the lubricant it was the
illumination it was the energy source
and all of a sudden with the discovery
of vast quantities of petroleum oil it
went away it became a horse of buggy
whip it was his gone gone happened very
quickly people it was joka they say how
did you go bankrupt well in the
beginning had happened very slowly but
in the end very fast when the pivot
happens it happens but I'm curious if it
was such a firm moving from whale oil to
petroleum oil was it also a like five
year period
I was a transition that happened
probably over maybe 20 years 20 years
okay so it wasn't much long there that's
this so crazy so Germany and Austria and
Ottoman Empire they couldn't they
couldn't gain access to oil what was one
of the reasons
there there various reasons there was
also a lot of alliances that were
created in the in the late 1800s and you
also had you know five or six or seven
armies that were all maybe maybe not
equal in strength but somewhere there
and the naval fleets you were discussed
you had how the world was colonized we
remember that Portugal Netherlands
Belgium these are countries that had
vast colonies but they were very small
they did not have powerful armies and
then that that war ends in 1918 in
November and it was repatriation with
the Germans and you had Woodrow Wilson's
fourteen points and I think everyone
most people in the Germanic countries
felt like they were hard done by and
there was that the world war one never
actually ended and that's with the rise
of the Nazis in the 1930s and then World
War two would start 1939 and after
making an alliance with the Russians
what does what does adolf hitler do with
Operation Barbarossa he goes any attacks
the Soviet Union why oil well they were
the first the first thing that they
wanted to get was the oil fields of Baku
they were effectively trading gold for
commodities and that was not a
sustainable trade in the long run
once again oil was one of the lesser
lesser talked about key elements of
World War two this was also really
interesting my family has armenian roots
and we have used to have like an army
Nikken there used to be an area in baku
that we used to live in and i remember
reading about the history and how there
was actually I think it was if I'm right
1910 I think that New York and Paris I
think were the two or in London I think
were the most populous cities and had
the highest population growth per year
and then all of a sudden randomly Baku
appeared on the map as a high having the
ha fastest population growth it was
because of the discovery of oil Caspian
Sea yeah yeah so I remember that being
something that was like wow people
move to oil by the everything they put
everything on the line to move to oil
and to bill you out in Texas and other
places too big land rush yeah land rush
in Texas as well yeah okay so this is
beautiful no knowing more about the
history and I wish we could you know
chat more about it maybe we can a bit
more if you're interested towards that
so the the book my electrician drives a
Porsche so this is the car that you
drove your environmentalist book tour in
zero emission book tour and you went to
what is that about
25 cities or so about 25 cities people
will say I drove across the United
States and they'll say it was not a zero
emission book tour because I did charge
the car and I did use the electricity
source of all the various states and
some of those states some of that
electricity may have been derived from
coal well when you build it when you
have a coal-fired power plant it's it's
always over producing a little bit so I
always tell people in the beginning for
electrification of Transportation you
get a bit of a Murphy the first couple
of three five percent because the
electricity is being generated anyways
but in the long run of course it's to be
addressed with a renewable circuit where
you localized the energy creation and
it's used and cars in fact become the
balancer the battery in the car helps
the grid if you can stretch your mind
and it's already happening in certain
places of the world where that is the
the renewable sort of the filling to
fill the gap so we know why the way now
at the super charging stations
if depends where you live depends where
every jurisdiction in Seattle its
hydropower in in Wyoming it would be
probably coal and Texas might be wind
power or natural gas and then in solar
and maybe Florida in California places
like that depends where you live yeah so
I drove I drove a Tesla my mic book is
titled my electrician drives a Porsche
and people say why are you driving a
Tesla cross America ah my book has
nothing to do with fast cars Porsche
it's just how did a young electrician
find independent
success with his investments yeah and
it's the young electrician so it's
understanding and appreciating
electricity he wouldn't lightens his
family doctor
yeah the world has changed with all of
these trends that the pivot of a new
consumer society in emerging markets and
he is the one who adopts the electric
way of life he in the end of the book so
not to spoil it for anyone cuz it's not
that type of book but that's how all
these things come together and so to
embellish this and as I said before to
show people that the future is now I an
incumbent energy person was able to
without with absolute zero difficulty
drive eight thousand miles across
America the hard way and to talk about
energy and I did that in this electric
car which is from a company based in
Northern California named after a famous
serbo-croatian scientist and Iowa's joke
about that yes well of course yeah
now the electrician becoming enlightened
through understanding the importance of
electricity and then going in and
spreading that knowledge and also be
able to buy a Porsche himself is that
kind of the essence yeah it's it talks
about many things so if you look at the
people go to the internet they could see
all the different icons on the cover it
covers the the full mix and it's it's
interesting so it's a reversal no we get
a zoom in on the on the cover because I
think I'm where because yeah it's it's a
it's a reversal of roles where the
millennial who is not a doctor is the
one in lightning his baby boomer friend
and and and the starring role is guess
what copper if the world is going
towards electrification that
electrification requires copper so
people need to understand that we're
bringing back the role of the realistic
environmentalist I like to you know
highlight that we're gonna require the
extraction of copper nothing comes for
free Allen people have to choose if you
it's like 11th grade algebra what you
take from one side of the equation you
have to give to the other
you can't just wave your arm around
say I don't want to have no more coal
power plants or no more diesel trucks
well that's fine but there's a cause and
effect because we society needs these
things we you know we can have more
clever ways to utilize them but oil is
energy energy without the use of fossil
fuels is increased electrification and
guess what electrification requires
copper the way we generate it the way we
transfer it and the way you and I as
consumers utilize it so it only 20% of
the world's energy mix today is
electricity 80 percent is something else
eventually it all ends up as electricity
so it's not like a Mad Max movie where
the last barrel of oil sells for a
million dollars I believe there's value
in oil it's a it's a really really
special thing we're not going to be
burning it for transportation fuels
we're gonna be taking that oil and
processing it into something for society
one of those other 45 things where as we
are gonna require more copper and that's
gonna come from guess what mining teach
teach us about copper real quick because
I think everybody thinks of lithium-ion
as yeah well that that's in the battery
so lithium in a battery but if you look
at those three silos we're consumers we
utilize energy okay if we're not
utilizing energy there's no reason to
make more of it right so when you
utilize almost everything you buy Allen
comes with an electrical cord suckle at
the back of it copper Cooper it's copper
as in the cord itself the winding
windings and windings of a transformer
the windings of a motor when you buy and
with from the socket went into the
device when you buy an air conditioning
unit that thing has 15 pounds of copper
a little one the little splits is over
you buy it's got wires home coils copper
it's got motors it's the windings of the
motors then it's electrically we're
connected refrigerators have lots of
copper absolutely and then if you look
at the the way electricity is moved from
point A to point B I'll even say there's
only three ways to move energy
big energy you can do it with a pipeline
oil and gas you can move it with a
railroad or a ship and you can move it
with electricity means you make
electricity and you transfer it a couple
thousand miles to where the consumer can
utilize the copper grid a grid but the
cable itself is not copper there alloys
light alloy light alloys because they're
the coppers grain heavy aluminum and
other things the other things absolutely
okay and so okay so interesting so
copper so heavily actually it's the
Achilles heel the Keystone the glue
copper is irreplaceable in this
transaction it's remarkable and guess
what
copper is infinitely recyclable all the
copper we that we've mined almost all of
it is still here you know Moses didn't
throw his copper away Julius Caesar
didn't throw his copper way Napoleon
didn't throw his copper away and today
people recycle copper it's infinitely
has the same properties we keep using it
over and over and over and because of
the magnificence of copper we are able
that is the secret weapon it's the way
we're going to be able to wean ourselves
off of fossil fuels because it enables a
wind park it takes five times more
copper to make a wind park then it does
a coal at the thermal coal power plant
each wind wind turbine is a motor copper
windings the copper has to be
distributed to the base has to be
stepped up the voltage has to be
collected between the hundred or two
hundred different towers and then it's
sent to society or to industry way more
copper same with solar power same with
the electric car the electric bus these
things take four five six as much as 10
times more copper for the same
application than doing it the old way
using thermal coal or what have you so
people have to have to recognize this it
is an absolute it's science and nothing
comes for free where does the copper
come from most people don't don't
probably appreciate that there are very
few copper mines that give society the
car
for that we use every day and once again
America has relative independence there
is a large copper endowment in the
United States talking like 10% of world
copper and that's a good thing today
it's yeah 10% is mined 10% of global
coppers mined in the United States but
we have vast reserves of copper so we'll
be okay with that other countries they
don't have the copper endowment so we
have fossil fuels but we also have
copper and we've got as you said
innovation technology and in a really
brilliant work force that are the
leaders even though sometimes as the
example we use with green energy the
Chinese have embraced it a little bit
quicker and maybe scaled it but but
there is a big opportunity for for
society and for investors around the
world to me what was just going through
my mind was the evolution of humans on
this plane and how we ran a lot of
people ran to the United States and
tried to gain independence and manifest
all of this land of ownership in North
America and then that enabling kind of
the United States to become what it is
today having all this land
I'm from coast to coast access to water
access to the resources inland that we
have here and really jump-starting a big
economic and political boom into the
last 250 years that we've been around
copper who would have thunk thank you
for sharing that and for and for sharing
so much more about the global energy
matrix it's our time 420 okay so let's
let's ask you a couple questions on the
way out maybe one of the questions that
we should ask you is about what what's
kind of going on with the rise of this
spending class like Millennials and Gen
Z years people that are a little bit
younger where where are they playing
into the equation along with the old
money that is currently involved in the
energy
industry the millennial bulge which
America has I think 87-88 million
Millennials China which has a population
of 1.3 seven billion they've got over
400 million Millennials in in their case
over a hundred million of graduated
university typically in STEM fields
science technology engineering and math
and your behavior the way you guys live
your lives the way your urbanizing I
think in many applications you guys have
no interest in living in the suburbs of
Kansas City you'd rather live in
gentrify an area of downtown Kansas City
yep in that example I can show you a
cluster of 40 people that collectively
maybe have never had a driver's license
25 years old and you guys are and you
guys are now sharing one uber driver on
average the service is 25 30 40 people
whatever it is and you people say well
well the car still driving those two or
three hundred miles a day or whatever it
would be in not quite you have to look
at the 30 cars that are never going to
be made yeah because I'm not into the
energy input into making those 30 cars
in a place to park those 30 cars and I
you can duplicate that over hundreds of
thousands of examples in cities around
the world I don't care if it's Budapest
Hungary or or Shanghai or or Mexico City
or San Francisco I travel the world
uber works everywhere almost every city
I'm not gonna say all of them but almost
every city there are there are bird
rivers and if you look at when you scale
that in the course of time this is gonna
have a dramatic impact on the amount of
these old things that you want no part
you want access but you don't want to
ownership all right and that's gonna
have an impact so if I was to tell the
the large automotive manufacturers the
the big three and they always jockey for
number one they make around ten million
passenger vehicles a year Volkswagen
Toyota General Motors if I was to go to
the chairman of Toyota and say you know
what you're gonna sell 10% less cars
because these Millennials aren't buying
up a million cars less that's cause for
alarm
yeah and they know it's happening it is
happening it's happening in real time
but it's not just gonna be 10% it's
gonna be probably a larger number so if
you look in the year 2030 we sell right
now 90 million passenger up light
vehicles on an annual basis on a global
scale is the number gonna be 110 million
in 2030 or 80 well guess what I think
it's gonna be some number lower than
than the current number and that's a big
deal yeah and of those cars of that 80
million or whatever that number is gonna
be it's a forecast there's gonna be a
percentage of them that are electric
there's gonna be a percentage greater
percentage of professional uber drivers
that's all they do and they're gonna
want a technologically advanced car that
has a lot less repairs and maintenance
and then you're gonna have a lot fewer
Millennials because the ones I just used
in the example that are twenty five well
they're gonna be thirty-seven
thirty-eight years old still not gonna
have a driver's license and they're
gonna have no interest in buying a car
you know and it's just gonna it's gonna
compound and magnify and magnify mega
file access rather than ownership wreck
and that's very interesting how it just
applies directly to car manufacturing so
close to the hearts and think of the
energy input into making all those cars
huge energy input huge energy use as
well if we're carpooling three people in
a car to a destination that we don't
even know each other yeah that's four
that's less cars that in term of the
energy as well as less of the oil that's
being used as well very valuable insight
there
a quick question about globalization
where do you see the United States and
China in the Middle East and Russia and
Europe how do you see us working
together and how do you see kind of both
the Peter Thiel perspective how do you
see zero to one happening how do you see
innovations happening and how do you see
the one-to-many happen and be honest if
you don't see us working together say it
that's thank you the American the
American politician operates on a
four-year election cycle that's just the
fact and the in China it they've let
people the economy do what you want
become wealthy but just leave the
politics to us the planned economy and
that's that's the system that they have
I'm not saying it's right or wrong and
they look at things in the long long
75% of American politicians are lawyers
they learn how to argue for a living
yeah so they can you can tell them
you're gonna be Pro this and they'll
argue and then like at like in college
debate class okay now you're against it
and they'll just flip it and make it
they know their professional lawyers
they could argue the other way and they
always vote on the company line it's
blue or it's red okay a little bit
different now with the Donald in power
China's a little different the average
all the political will sort of caught a
shanty in China they're engineers they
don't to build things yeah they they
took as the STEM fields punishment II
cone Ashanti what's gonna Shanti Kenosha
day means to know or to have knowledge
of in Latin or Italian the cone Ashanti
is those that no it's it's a group of
people that are really smart the cone
Ashanti the coefficient the kind of
shanty I love yeah that's a good word
and so I look at it they have this long
long long vision and I give you one
anecdotal story Richard Nixon would
visit China in 1972 but the year before
he would send Henry Kissinger 1971 he
meant was you in lie and he asked you in
line this is also the people have
sometimes a mistake in this way were
between Mao and Jew and lie he asked him
what do you think are the implications
of the French Revolution and you and I
looks at him and says you know I think
it's still or too early to tell you know
now he thought he was joking was
actually meant the Prague Spring which
happened in 1969 but it just it just
shows you that it's chess 2030 moves in
advance you know so they're making
things and they're they're planning for
such a long cycle so how are these two
economies going to interact now in the
long run we don't know but in the short
run but I can tell you is that if the
election cycle changes and in 2020
someone else is elected all what's been
looked at in a negative or a positive
you press the reset button again and
depending on who is the president in
2020 be it an incumbent or be it someone
new that relationship will change once
again so we have to revisit now do you
think that then the coefficient a
perspective of have people that actually
understand
how to engineer a bright future and
having them kind of maybe be benevolent
people in power could be better than
pressing the reset before you what is a
wise person do if you understand this
it's the art of Judo judo is a martial
art where you don't attack you actually
just move away and you let you let the
they attack you and you you use their
force against themselves you know so
they know this they know there's 24
months left no one's gonna make big
decisions based on on this one election
in the election cycle another piece of
anecdotal information they can change
the rules for building nuclear power
plants relaxed legislation they can
lower the emission regulations for the
American automotive manufacturers but no
one cares because guess what in 2020 the
rules change and and someone else will
change it again
and they have to compete on a global
scale I'm talking about both of these
parties the people that build power
plants and the American automotive
manufacturers which only make 15% of the
world's cars the other 85% are made by
other people and if they've got
fuel-efficient technologically advanced
really cool cars the last thing they
want to make in the United States
anymore
is something that's you know like where
they got killed by the Japanese in the
mid 1980s because the cars just did not
cut the mustard the global energy matrix
so interesting okay
how about what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world the most
beautiful thing in the world well I tell
people I'll give people a tip and I've
been all over the world and I think when
you can share a great movie or a great
piece of art or a great piece of music
yeah but it's hard for people to have
the same taste I will suggest that
people open up their travel books and if
and when they go to Europe go to Croatia
pick an island bounce around the food is
fantastic
the prices are honest the water is
pristine no industry 1,100 islands to
choose from you can
it's Crowder you can go off the beaten
track no Louis Vitton Noguchi organic
food usually this is what we caught
today that's what we're growing that's
what you eat you're gonna have a
fantastic vacation I would just
recommend it to everyone even though if
it gets inundated by too many tourists
in a long long run Soviet but that's a
tip for everyone
go see Croatia it's beautiful yeah I
really was really appreciated both the
plug for Croatia but also the you know
UX that was a really beautiful way to
put it and also that you said that
sharing music or movie or art in these
different places in the world and being
able to bond with someone else
over that is really cool it's really
interesting people can follow me on
Twitter yes we have yes we have much
more in the bio as well yeah do you
think we're alone in the cosmos who
knows Neil deGrasse Tyson who's
brilliant and he people probably seen
this he says the difference between a
chimpanzee and the human being is like
1% yeah and so just think of the
brainpower difference or the intellect
so just imagine that cuz they're if
there's something else out there was 1%
smarter than us you know where would we
you know we face so who knows it's it's
a it's a big big world well do you think
that we're in a computer simulation no
you think this is base reality yeah why
not I believe so yeah why not why not
I'm here and you know enjoy it while you
got it
Gianni what a pleasure we learned a lot
today on the show with you thank you so
much thank you coming on huge thank you
thank you we'll have your book link in
the bio as well guys definitely check it
out my electrician drives a Porsche
audible comic paper book hardcover
softcover multiple languages yeah
multiple languages audible as well audio
do take the information that you learn
today about energy and about the way
that we use it the way that we're
transitioning with it the way that we've
grown with it and historically prospered
as a civilization with it take this
information and go and make some
with it don't just consume this but go
create something write about it make a
video about it go start a company about
it go create with this everyone
subscribe join the family leave your
comments below with your thoughts we'd
love to hear from you also join us on
patreon we need to continue supporting
the studio and growing our endeavor so
join us there and huge thank you huge
thank you for tuning in
thank you Ron Vargas or producing
director thank you guys thanks to our
previous patrons as well we greatly
appreciate you for tuning in much love
everyone stay sexy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]